bonjour à tous nous sommes là où il ya
un duo composé de deux voix et la nuque
ou l'ailé qui arrivent nous faut tous
ensemble depuis à peu près un an et demi
deux ans mais nous avons officialisé
notre duo il y a peu à peu près de trois
mois bon parlons notre nom du duo
puisque la hoya c'est pas très très
commun donc en fait c'est un composé de
nos deux prénoms donc là pour laura il
ya pour assia avec un haut en fait en
plein centre du mot pour représenter une
certaine union mais aussi un cercle qui
n'a pas vraiment de faim ont peu à peu
on a commencé à chanter ensemble à
écrire des chansons ensemble et ce après
midi on va vous en présenter
quelques-unes d'entre elles donc la
première composition s'appelle my
prairie babe mais qu'on aime beaucoup
appelé m pipi en référence à une chanson
de michael jackson qui s'appelle pays où
haïti mais qui est aussi connue sous le
nom de près les yankees alors pour cette
chanson acia et est venu me voir au
lycée un jour maps et laura faut que je
te montre absolument j'ai trouvé des
accords et donc on aller dans la salle
de musique elle m'a montré et j'ai
trouvé ça absolument géniale et je les
ai refait au piano et en ajoutant un peu
un peu ma patte parce que de mon de mon
passé le pianiste et au fur et à mesure
on a commencé à faire une mélodie à crir
des paroles et en très peu de temps en
moins d'une heure on a on a créé cette
chanson voilà dans ce qui concerne
l'histoire de la chanson - elle parle
d'une relation amoureuse assez difficile
et non comprises par interlocuteur mais
lors du refrain en fait il se rend
compte de la souffrance qu'il subit et
décide de lâcher complètement les armes
donc voici mp by michael ebeid
oh
rappelez vous
oh oui
à eux deux ils étaient saines
sauvage et la mi mai
souhaite
tous
a plaidé
m
au bilan les frais
boulogne bicher
m de tout
puis au mal et les costumes
se priver
au château
oh
après l'événement
après liv est rappelé et m'a privé map
l'éditer
après l'été
vous l'aimez
ma prime a pris la prairie
m
go
au mali
on souffre ip
washington
où
oh
merci beaucoup merci merci alors
maintenant on va passer à notre seconde
composition qui s'appelle d'or la haye
bon qui bouge un peu plus vous vous
l'accordé et en fait quand on a écrit
ses chansons s'est basé sur une sorte de
jeu de rôle comme si l'oreille mois nous
étions en couple et que nous parlions
l'une à l'autre en chantant celle qu en
fait dans ce couple les deux personnes
du couple ne savent pas vraiment 6ème
encore en fait et vous allez beaucoup
entendre certaines paroles sans hockey
wright qu'on peut traduire par ok dac
ça montre un peu dans ce couple il ya
plus du tout d'intérêt
il ya plus du tour il ya plus du temps
y'a plus rien d'un scoop
donc vous vous laisse écouter darling
aïe ok
ok on a
c'est ok
en
oui
non
marina dont la berline à aider si le
story ce cas-ci pluie sur be ok
ap
tarhoni du système
ban à dominante des
m
ah ok
à
non
marina rick wright pas plein
dans les allemands taille
sauf elle
delwit librairie 0 d'ampli dans les
niayes décide le sort mieux que naples
avis ok mais aulas
ok
c'est une des formes hamad
je tends me you wanna que vomi
à dementieva
et donc il
non
c'est vrai
m
les yankees
dans l'achat en ligne d'essai est arrivé
au caire
il y aura
ok
oh la la
merci merci
maintenant on va passer à notre dernière
chanson mais ce n'est pas seulement la
dernière chanson c'est aussi la toute
première chanson qu'on a écrite ensemble
avec laura je me rappelle très bien on
était dans la salle de musique mots
comme d'habitude d'ailleurs et
elle a commencé improvisé quelques
quelques notes comme ça sur le coup
l'ailé et en fait j'ai commencé à poser
des paroles dessus et ça a commencé
comme ça et puis pour raconter un peu
l'histoire de cette chanson
bon ça parle encore une fois d'un amour
difficile je crois qu'on est devenus les
experts d'ailleurs de ça mais bon et
donc en fait c'est une personne qui
souffre beaucoup d'un amour donc et elle
elle pense à son amour et au fur et à
mesure de la chanson quand on arrive aux
refrains cette personne se rend compte
qu'il faut aller de l'avant il faut pas
rester ancré dans le passé il faut
tourner la page et c'est pour ça que
andy heineken qui veut dire laissons le
politiquement correct mais ça veut dire
je m'en fous et donc voilà on va vous
faire écouter notre dernière chance on a
manqué
la tête ou deux
tu sais
à moi
pavel choyés
ce fort gay
avant
où
baa
d'entrée
adam
lequel
elle n'a
et des mots
m
guèye
non
v joaillier tout fauguet nous
avait fini
m
e
des mots
le caniveau
hu
à
oh
hu
donc m
non
paul et ken
et non
oh
de l'est
tellement
aliments
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup bonne journée à tous et
merci à tedx de nous avoir donné
l'opportunité de nous produire et merci
à vous de nous avons écouté